the cognitive dissonance and unhinged
misdirection from Trump associates after
news broke of the first criminal charges
in the Trump Russia investigation has
been stunning and I want to start with
you today buckle up and get ready we're
starting with Corey Lewandowski Trump's
former campaign manager Fox news.com as
I mentioned mostly no mention of this
story all weekend but Saturday mornings
Fox and Friends team did talk about it
and mostly they used news of the then
breaking charges against a trump
official that we now know to be Paul
Manafort they used it as an opportunity
to slam other networks for overreacting
they bring on Corey Lewandowski and
Corey Lewandowski says when asked about
his comment on the upcoming indictment
of a Trump associate in the Trump Russia
investigation
Lewandowski says the real story isn't
being told by the media and it relates
to the Clinton administration what let's
take a listen to Lewandowski oh the
White House your reaction to that the
dam is breaking it said we will never
gonna hold the water back give me a
break okay
look the speculation is so insane right
now what we should be focusing on other
continued lies of the Clinton
administration to continue the fallacies
that they perpetuate look Robert Miller
is doing his job whatever that entails
and he has now filed charges against
somebody that we don't know what they
are we don't know who they're against
wait the Clinton administration like the
one from 1992 to the year 2000 that
started 25 years ago and ended 17 years
ago or does he mean Hillary Clinton who
of course didn't have an administration
I'm all for reminiscing about the 1990s
like most Millennials but the Clinton
administration has what to do with any
of this and I say let's not stop there
let's go back to Jimmy Carter did Jimmy
Carter really divest from that peanut
farm or did he use clever legal tricks
to hide his interests in the family
business I thought there were never
going to be any charges period Korie but
now that there are the focus has to be
the Clinton administration and of course
it's never explained well what do you
mean are you talking about Bill
Clinton's administration or are you
saying Hillary Clinton when she was
Secretary of State and
it's very easy to just write this off
and say Corey lewandowski's living in an
alternate reality I don't know that he
is he's trying to put trumpets in an
alternate reality and it works every
time on them and think for a second if
Hillary Clinton were the president right
now and there were rumors that I don't
know John Podesta was about to be
arrested would Fox News be singing this
tune that really we need to be talking
about the Bush administration or who
knows what of course not and this is not
Lewandowski in a fantasy world
this is Lewandowski knowing that
trumpets are bamboozled Abel and he's
trying to bamboozle them